jean françois xavier bellamy mon genre
qui nous sommes le 1er mai c'est donc la
trame est la traditionnelle journée de
mobilisation et 2 nombreux casseurs
pourraient s'infiltrer dans les cortèges
selon le ministre de l'intérieur qui
parle de 1000 à 2000 personnes
est ce que vous redoutez aujourd'hui une
flambée de violences à paris en
particulier on peut que la redoute est
en effet puisque le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même attire l'attention
sur le risque que représentent ces
violences ce qui compte maintenant c'est
que il ne fasse pas seulement la liste
des menaces possibles mais qu'il propose
aussi une manière efficace de réagir
face à ces violences depuis trop
longtemps les manifestations sont
pollués perturbé par ces blacks blocs
ces casseurs que l'on dit venir
d'ailleurs y compris d'autres pays
européens où d'autres pays du monde
seulement pour pouvoir casser détruire
abîmé et je crois que ce qui est en jeu
c'est bien sûr non seulement la sécurité
l'ordre public qui sont troublés dans
notre pays depuis très longtemps
ce qui est injuste aussi la liberté de
manifester pacifiquement
la manifestation est un droit évidemment
fondamental mais ce droit doit s'exercer
dans le respect des règles qui en
république s'impose toujours mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est l'expression démocratique
pacifique de toutes les manifestations
qui est menacée par cette flambée de
violence que le gouvernement depuis trop
longtemps on n'arrive pas à juguler
est-ce que ce 1er mai peut-être
l'occasion d'un nouveau souffle pour le
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui semble
du point de vue en tout cas de
mobilisation marquer un peu le pas
depuis quelques semaines
tu vas là pour faire des pronostics sur
l'évolution de ce mouvement
ce qui compte c'est je crois que notre
pays puisse retrouver l'ordre dont il a
besoin
la concorde qui doit unir la société
même malgré les divisions et que nous
sachions retrouver une manière de
débattre ensemble de façon démocratique
y compris lorsque nous sommes en
désaccord
ma conviction c'est que ce que disaient
les gilet jaune au tout début que ce
mouvement était parfaitement justifiée
on le voit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec
la remontée des prix de l'essence du
gasoil
des carburants en général qui fait
évidemment beaucoup de mal au pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et surtout qui
touchent directement ceux qui ont besoin
de ce carburant pour travailler pour
aller à leur travail ou bien pour mener
leurs activités
il faut évidemment une réponse sur cette
question et cette réponse elle passe par
une vraie baisse de la fiscalité mais il
faut que cette inquiétude puisse
s'exprimer là encore dans un cadre
démocratique et dans un cadre paisible
alors la réponse au mot social il ya eu
dans un premier temps en décembre un
certain nombre de mesures d'ordre
pratique annoncée par le président la
république et puis il ya eu la semaine
dernière les réponses à la suite du camp
des pannes nationale le premier ministre
a détaillé le calendrier des mesures
c'était lundi est ce que dans ce qu'a
annoncé le président de la république
vous voyez de l'ambition on a du mal à
voir exactement où nous conduisent ces
annonces et quand vous parliez de
détails et le calendrier des mesures on
a plutôt eu droit au calendrier des
réflexions des lettres de mission des
commissions a créé le premier ministre
nous dit qu'on va réfléchir
collectivement à la manière de voir
collectivement comment on peut avoir des
résultats sur la question de l'emploi à
tout ça n'est pas très sérieux quand
même
monsieur macron a été ministre pendant
plusieurs années monsieur philippe est
premier ministre depuis deux ans
maintenant on a du mal à comprendre
qu'on est toujours besoin d'empiler les
diagnostics les uns sur les autres alors
que maintenant il faut agir et il faut
agir dans une direction très précise qui
consiste à faire en sorte que la dépense
publique puisse baisser dans notre pays
ce que voient les français c'est que la
dépense publique n'a cessé d'augmenter
que simultanément les services publics
n'ont cessé de se dégrader
il faut qu'on arrive à retrouver un peu
de bon sens un peu d'efficacité et là
dessus il faut un cap clair et
aujourd'hui malheureusement ce cap clair
je crois que nous ne l'avons pas c'est
assez inquiétant d'ailleurs d'avoir le
sentiment d'être dans ce brouillard qui
ne cessent de durer alors que nous
aurions besoin plus que jamais de
retrouver une vision partagée pour faire
face à ces grands défis qui nous
attendent au menu de maquereaux
non c'est non pas qu'ils renonçaient
m'enfin 2 fait ça revient un peu à ça à
la suppression de 120 mille
fonctionnaires pendant son quinquennat
pour vous c'est une erreur ça il aurait
fallu maintenir cet objectif il faut
évidemment maintenir un objectif
fondamental qui est la baisse de la
dépense je vous êtes sur ce sujet là ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un autre en toc
sur la dépense publique on peut on ne
peut pas considérer qu'on est un ultra
orthodoxe seulement parce qu'on estime
qu'il était impossible jeux conçus sur
le point précis de la dépense publique
oui mais il ya et le centre de gravité
du débat dans notre pays est
complètement déséquilibrée parce que on
vit dans un pays qui ne sait pas faire
un budget en huile et d études montrent
souvent là le centre de gravité sur la
dépense publique mais c'est un sujet
majeur mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est pas être un ultra
orthodoxe kke de considérer
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un immense gâchis
que cette dépense publiquement maîtrisé
qui constituera demain les impôts de nos
enfants qui est comme la dette que nous
leur laissons à cause de notre
incapacité à faire face au présent c'est
pas un investissement pour l'avenir
cette dette c'est le fait de ce
fonctionnement que nous ne savons pas
maîtrisé de notre état deux
administrations et donc oui bien sûr il
faut un objectif ambitieux de baisse de
la dépense publique
et oui cette baisse de la dépense
publique est la condition pour une
véritable baisse de la pression fiscale
qui comme vous le savez est en france
parmi les plus élevés au monde
aujourd'hui malheureusement parce qu'il
n'y a pas de baisse de la dépense
publique parce que le président de la
république a renoncé à la seule promesse
qu'il avait faite sur ce sujet eh bien
on sait déjà que ces annonces c'est 17
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
vont être dépensées vont peser sur les
entreprises à travers ce qu'on appelle
la suppression de niches fiscales qui
n'est rien d'autre qu'une augmentation
de la fiscalité les républicains dont
vous conduisez donc la liste pour les
élections européennes ont opéré une
remontée très importante dans les
intentions de vote depuis quelques mois
il ya quelques mois c'était entre 8 et
10% lalinde étude 1 les sondages vous
crédite 15 et demi pour cent
alors on demande à vos amis si c'est
l'effet bellamy est ce que vous pensez
que c'est l'effet ben ali non je crois
vous savez que on en fait beaucoup sur
les têtes de liste mais nous ce que nous
vivons dans cette campagne depuis le
début c'est d'abord une aventure
d'equipe c'est une liste qui réunit j'ai
été investis depuis le début avec le
choix de vous placer en tête de liste
n'a pas fait l'unanimité chez vous même
au sein de votre parti vous le savez
bien que mal bien sûr je me suis moi
même me poser la question de savoir si
c'est me faisait l'unanimité avec vous
même c'est surtout mon si c'était pas
c'était pas du tout une évidence pour
moi j'étais pas programmés pour cette
campagne mais je me suis posé l'action
or si je fais le mieux placé pour être
utile à ses idées que nous défendons
ensemble ce qui compte le plus c'est
pouvoir parler d'europe et peut-être
cette dynamique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
elle est le résultat de ce travail que
nous menons depuis trois mois partout en
france sur le terrain tous les jours ce
sera le cas encore aujourd'hui vient
nous allons au contact des français pour
parler avec eux de l'europe que nous
voulons c'est aussi ça vivre un moment
démocratique c'est pouvoir proposer un
choix clair avant nous avons un projet
75 proposition proposait justement un
cap qui nous permet ensuite d'agir
efficacement
plutôt que de remédier par
d'interminables grand débat à une
absence de débat que nous n'avons pas su
avoir avant les scrutins électoraux
qu'est ce qu'elle vous apprend cette
campagne sur la france et sur les
français elle m'apprend que la france
mais je le savais déjà comme élu local
depuis dix ans je le vois tous les jours
maintenant partout en france est
traversée de de tension très profonde
passé douloureusement fracturée elle
m'apprend que beaucoup de français
travaillent et ne parviennent pas à s'en
sortir et le vivent difficilement bien
sûr elle m'apprend que nous avons de
grandes inquiétudes devant notre avenir
ce don au fond la question de la dette
est aussi l'un des symptômes mais elle
m'apprend aussi que nous avons toutes
les ressources pour pouvoir avancer
moi je suis frappé tous les jours de
voir sur le terrain des chefs
d'entreprise qui se battent des
agriculteurs qui se démène malgré toutes
les difficultés des salariés je suis
frappé de voir à quel point beaucoup se
se donne pour cultiver le lien social je
pense aux associations je pense aux élus
locaux qui font le maillage de cette
france qui tient encore debout par le
terrain plutôt que par le haut et au
fond si on savait redonner un peu
d'oxygène à tous ceux qui travaillent en
france à tous ceux qui s'engagent ainsi
je suis sûr qu'on aurait de quoi
regarder l'avenir avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé vous avez choisi pour
slogan de campagne pour formule de
campagne refonder l'europe rétablir la
france qui ne proposent pas aujourd'hui
de l'informer transformer refonder
l'europe la question c'est effectivement
de savoir dans quelle direction on veut
la refonder nous nous croyons de façon
très claire à une refondation de
l'europe qui permettent à nos pays
d'être plus fort dans la mondialisation
de demain nous ne croyons pas
contrairement au rassemblement national
que nous serons plus forts en défaisant
l'europe et ça a été le discours pendant
très longtemps du rassemblement national
mais en campagne à part de notre
souveraineté et nous ne croyons pas non
plus contrairement à monsieur macron que
l'europe doivent devenir le synonyme
d'une dépossession démocratique monsieur
macron a expliqué dans son discours de
la sorbonne d'athènes que dans la
mondialisation l'échelle de nos états et
est une échelle périmés le croyant pas
nous ne croyons pas qu'il faille
transférer notre souveraineté à
l'échelle européenne ça n'a jamais été
le sens du projet européen et c'est la
raison pour laquelle effectivement il
faut un projet clair aujourd'hui
malheureusement la liste de la
république en marche nous dit qu'elle
n'a pas de projet qu'elle ne dévoilerait
seulement le 9 mai pour un parti qui se
prétendait profondément européen dévoilé
son programme quinze jours avant
l'élection c'est je crois un peu léger
nous nous avons fait ce choix d'une
campagne de terrain et de vision et
c'est ce que nous essayons de développer
ensemble
merci françois xavier beulin merci et
bonne journée